hello guys hi there congratulations hi
thank you uh jabuki I was watching
another interview where the filmmakers
were talking about how much they valued
your ability to improv and play around
with the material so it was making me
wonder do you have an example of like a
big random swing you took in the booth
that now we can see in the final film
uh there was a lot of splat interaction
that ended up making it into the final
film that
um what I loved about the process is
that they really were taking what we did
in the booth and then you know kind of
running off and then coming back with
something that incorporated what we did
in the last session so uh I think the
dynamic between Ethan and splat a lot of
the improvisation ended up working its
way into that relationship feel for both
of you I had seen that a little bit in
another interview that you were all kind
of wowed by how they didn't just use
your voice performance but they picked
up on a lot of the physical elements you
were doing in the sound booth as well so
for both of you is there anything you
see in the animated version of yourself
that just made you stop and go like I
can't believe they pulled that
I can't believe how much I look like
Kurt Russell
they write it for him no no you sure
yeah it was for me okay all right
um for me what really Shook Me Up was
there's a Seymour Meridian and Ethan are
talking to each other and Ethan kind of
readjusting the chair and like does this
thing that I do in real life but I'm
like I've never sat in that booth there
was not a chair in that Booth even if I
sat in that Booth they wouldn't have
seen it where did they get this from
like what video did you pull this from
so it wasn't even just the
um voiceover sessions it kind of was
just like
everything that they had at their
disposal was really impressive whatever
they did and you did it works these
characters feel full and real as can be
I loved it
um Dennis is someone who re-watches The
Day After Tomorrow quite often I
absolutely have to ask this did you ever
talk to Jake about the fact that the
last time you two worked together you
played father and son in a film that
addressed how we treated our environment
yeah wait and just like this movie we
were never in the same room together
either
that's uh you know the only difference
is is that this time he's coming to look
for me rather than the other way around
but make make a third one I don't care
like what
if I'm wrong on this but I think it's
been a pretty long time since you've
done another animated feature so is
there anything about the voice acting
experience on strange world that would
make you know battle for Terror you go
like wow I can't believe that's how this
process works today well this is this is
like it's a it's total it's totally
different it was so easy these guys make
it so easy here and uh it went just
beyond anything I imagine it's like I
kind of feel like I don't have an
imagination compared to what they did
and they've it's like they invented
colors again all over again with this
movie and it's such a great story that
everyone can relate to at the same time
all right I'll warn you I'll wrap with a
little bit of a heavier one but uh given
the focus this movie puts on how each
generation can change the world around
everyone I'll kind of turn that in
towards the industry jabuki is share a
more experienced actor you've worked
with recently that kind of set you up
for success and paved the way forward
for you in a positive manner and then
same for you Dennis but maybe with a
newer actor you met that uh you know
they you think that they're able to
change the industry going forward for
the better
um
to Ray uh definitely working with Issa
she
really values um empowering people I
think that is a
really special and beautiful trait that
she specifically possesses and that is
like it's invaluable having those people
who are willing to just freely give
advice and freely I don't know like put
you on the things that you have no way
of learning other than doing I think
that's so so crucial
excellent choice yeah and I think Tim
Oliphant should
play the dad Nick Parker and the remake
of The Parent Trap
I will watch that in a heartbeat yeah
see there you go is that something that
that's happening today I just worked
with them and I think he'd be perfect I
think we need to will this I'm not going
to freak I'm going to obsess over this
now thank you both so much for your time
today huge congratulations on Strange
World see you later